thank you
yeah so I what I would like to talk
about if I think that we have much
better understanding of certain things
which sort of have been puzzling for
some time and well as we all know the a
lot of success of machine learning has
been based on models and training
algorithms which are extraordinarily
complex it is not very easy to get some
sort of idea of what are the key
components underlying that success and
now at least I think we can identify one
part of that and that's the idea of
interpolation which Peter already talked
about a little bit in the beginning I'll
talk more about this so I'll talk about
interpolation and its consequences now
if you sort of look at the classical
setting for supervised machine learning
and you see that the goal of machine
learning algorithm sort of in the
classical statistical setting imagine
that I have data and I'm assuming that
at sample iid from some distribution and
so on then I would like to find an
algorithm whose output is essentially
the best possible predictor and the best
possible predictor is given by the
expected the minimizing the expected
value over unseen data of some loss
function so that's kind of the goal of
machine learning is to find well given
data of course something close to the
self star now what do we do in practice
well in practice we use some version of
algorithmic empirical risk minimization
we take a family of functions for
example neural networks and all that
using say stochastic gradient descent
that's what's typically done we find we
try to minimize the loss over the
training data okay so that they in
risk and this is a kind of true or
expected risk so if this output is close
to this one we're done right that's
great and then the question is well
wouldn't it be reasonable to assume that
if we want this two things to be the
same then the corresponding objective
function should also be the same well if
you look at sort of classical
generalization bounds they're all of the
following form you can call them VZ week
what you see is what you get because
what you get is the expected risk and in
most of the bounds that we have it's
bounded by the empirical risk what is
the empirical risk it's this quantity
and how does the bound work well you
have the expected risk which is smaller
than the empirical risk plus some sort
of a complexity term typically something
like square root of Z away and when C is
some measure of complexity of the
problem and the idea that F n increases
they have two things converge and you
get the same
now how does it depend on this
complexity term C well if you again if
you look at this classical type of
analysis they're based on the
bias-variance tradeoff
which is the idea that f the model
complexity increases you
well when the model complexity is low
you have underfitting when the model
complexity is how you have overfitting
your empirical loss is low but you
expect it loss is high and the goal of
machine learning is to find a model
which is somewhere in the middle of that
you shape the textbook corollary of that
is that a model with zero training error
is ography to the training data and
we'll generalize poorly and we will call
this interpolation just because
mathematically that's what interpolation
is okay now an example from the paper
understanding deep learning requires
rethinking generalization they train the
standard architecture of a neural
network they get 100% accuracy the test
accuracy is quite good right it's about
90% so it looks like there is no penalty
here for everything that seems to
contradict what I just showed you before
though those classical bounds well it
doesn't quite contradict this on its own
it's very suggestive but you can say
well what maybe test accuracy should be
hundred percent right then the BA the
bounds would apply it's just a little
bit loose here so let me show you an
experiment that we did which is much
more extreme than that and this is with
my students you are mine sumak Mandel we
did the following experiment you take M
NIST it's a 10 class problem of course
so you when you so you randomized a
fixed percentage of the labels so you
take a sorry of the data so you take say
60% of your data of the training data
and you are assigned to that random
labels and then you use say kernel
machines a Laplace kernel to feed the
data exactly and by fitting it exactly
it has essentially numerically zero l2
loss well something like 10 to the minus
2
so this is the maximum amount of
overfitting which is numerically
possible now you can see that you know
if their output if you know you had the
best possible predictor you can never
beat this noise level so the Green Line
here is a Bayes optimal which is the
best optimal predictor now of course
well 90% is a random chance because it's
a 10 class problem so you can see that
even for very high noise levels these
predictors including neural network
Gaussian kernel are quite far from
random noise and only a little bit worse
than the optimal predictor so there is
no penalty for kind of overfitting
penalty that is this kind of benign
overfitting
even when you interpolate even when you
interpolate with zero loss if this some
sort of strange phenomenon argumented
that it's not that's actually the
practice of deep learning at least as
described by the practitioners so ruslan
in fact gave a talk here two years ago
in the program on deep learning and his
tutorial he described how to train your
networks and she said well the best way
to solve the problem is to get zero
training error that may be not the end
of it you do other things after that but
even with that you already get good
result and that at the very least at the
first step toward it so in a sense what
machine learning does now is to start
with interpolation so if we don't
understand interpolation the argument
goes well it would be very difficult to
understand how much how deep learning
works
now I should point out this is really
not completely new phenomenon and leo
breiman wrote some years ago wrote a
note reflections of the refereeing
papers for nips and yes several
questions the first one why don't
heavily parameterize neural network over
feed the data and well I don't know if
you can guess when it was written ninety
five twenty years later
young lacunae actually just last year if
a deep learning break some basic rules
of statistics presumably based on some
of the similar kind of observations so I
think now we can resolve this issue and
finally we can sort of reconcile
statistics with this type of phenomena
okay so what is the plan for the talk
first I will talk about statistical
theory of interpolation showing that we
actually have some methods which are
statistically valid and interpolate the
data that's number one to I will discuss
the landscape of machine learning and in
particular a phenomenon we call the
double descent which kind of combines
the U curve in what we observe in modern
models and three I'll very briefly talk
about optimization because I think this
is really crucial part of why the things
work okay so let's start with first let
me point out why classical let me just
narrow down this argument a little bit
why classical bounds have difficulty
with us because well what what happens
with a classical bound when you're an
empirical risk is zero this term
disappears completely so the expected
risk must be bounded completely by the
model complexity and
therefore what we need we need to
basically have a bound in terms of this
well what would that mean if you look at
the figure I showed before suppose you
look at something like 70% noise level
that means that you need to bound this
red line between the green line and the
dashed horizontal line well what you
would need therefore for the bound is
square root of C away and away and well
there are other ways to write this but
this is kind of a typical one to be
between point seven and point nine so
that's what you want you want it to be
correct which means that it has to be
bigger than point seven which is the
optimal one it has to be smaller than
point nine because otherwise it three
well right it's worse than noise and you
have to keep this as n goes to infinity
the problem is if we don't have any
bound of this form we don't have any
reason to think that they exist there
are some reason that at least bounds of
certain type don't exist like like that
and moreover a constant factor of two a
multiplicative factor of two would
invalidate any bound like this it has to
be exact
no not like exact up to a constant so if
this doesn't work what do we have well
let's just go very quickly over some
analysis that we have and see what can
explain interpolation and then what
cannot rather and then what can so VC
dimension rather make the complexity
type of bound cannot because of this and
what is happening is that you know you
have the training loss is equal to zero
it's not equal to the expected loss that
also applies to other types of bounds
regularization type analysis like
chicken of an early stopping his similar
form that's a slight simplification but
essentially the same algorithmic
stability also had this so none of this
bounds really can be hoped to work
however there is a different type of
bounds which are classical smoothing
bound and the derive what some type of
result which is kind of person Windows
or kernel smoothing there are different
names for that this result an Oracle
bound and by Oracle I mean that the
expected loss is approximately equal
to the optimal laws that can work
because there is no reason that this
none none of that is zero
of course this bounds are kind of less
satisfactory because we don't observe
expected loss we don't observe the
optimal laws so it's like bounding
something which we don't observe to
something else which we don't observe
okay that's maybe this is nicer but this
doesn't work so really most classical
analysis even though in principle they
could they don't support interpolation
however there is one really famous and
everybody knows that example it's one
nearest neighbor classifier one nearest
neighbor classifier very suggestive it
interpolated classified has a
non-trivial classical bound which to say
that it's twice bounded by twice its
losses bounded it's risk is bounded by
twice a base rate and its analysis is
not based on this type of complexity
bounds it's a completely different type
of analysis and so there is no reason
something like that cannot work and now
I'm going to give you an example of
something which is very much motivated
by one nearest neighbor yeah yeah pretty
bad yeah yeah so you want something like
that but much better
exactly yeah it would be very difficult
because if your constant is that wrong
by a factor of two you order to write
the norm based bound and then evaluate
the norm in principle you could but if
we don't know any examples of this and
again if your constant is off so you
have to get the constant exact then like
it has to be one plus Epsilon
stronger opposition to that right
because you could condition on the data
and use those arguments to talk about
what the additional expectations saying
why at each X I looks like Eddie and
this sort of bound come possibly between
because you you're predicting why I
which is wrong so that's kind of the
philosophically yeah even you are saying
even mathematically right right but
maybe there is some other bound which
goes well in any case okay but let me
just I'll discuss only I love this cuz
one kind of algorithm of this form and
the third joint work with Danielle and
there is part Dmitri and also there is a
follow up with Sasha Rockland and Sasha
typical so here here is idea so it's
kind of like a corner of smoothing
method except they're using a singular
kernel and the singular kernel has this
form so it is actually one of a distance
you can just think of this a big one of
a distance now one of a distance has a
singularity and you think well okay this
is not going to work but actually if you
multiply by eyes by the kernel and you
divide that by the Sun the singularity
cancels out and you get something which
is continuous it continues but it's not
smooth it doesn't have any derivative
that the singularity point so what you
see is something like that I'll describe
this a little bit more in a second and
the interesting thing is you can show
that this strange algorithm actually
it's not just consistent for both
classification regression but in a sense
it's statistically optimal in the
minimax
now let me just point out the kind of
implication of that well so imagine my
data just it's one-dimensional it's
linear plus noise now this algorithm is
going this is an example of this is
going to fit the data exactly so at
every data point you're very far from
the blue line which is the optimal
predictor we know that blue line is
optimal so it looks like I'm doing
terribly but actually if you take a
random point from this interval you're
doing just fine so somehow you're doing
very badly on your data but you're doing
just fine at a point choosing at random
from the interval that's a sort of very
content intuitive aspect of this and
apparently this is what's happening in
many of the Talcher isms and prices okay
one quick implication of this I there's
several examples right so here probably
everyone knows you take an image it's a
dog you add some noise to it which is
not visible very tiny amount it becomes
an ostrich right well here is the
theorem that you can prove if an in fact
Peter also mentioned this related aspect
of this if you have label noise then
your adversarial examples are going to
be asymptotically danced so you would
expect to see an adversarial example in
the neighborhood of every point I have
not saying this is the only way by which
this kind of examples appear and
probably not
there are other reasons they may appear
but I think this suggests that if you
take an interpolation seriously as a way
to train those models that seems to be
the way that it's done in practice then
you shouldn't be surprised when you get
something like that the math actually
suggests that you would have
well it's all now our payment okay so
now let me sort of so what have I shown
so far so I have given some results
showing the empirical validity of
interpolation particular for those
experiments when you're all nuts and
kernel machines and I've shown the
statistical validity interpolation there
are some rules which are optimal and
interpolate however there is a
disconnect here right and what does it
disconnect well the problem is that the
first one is erm and the second one is
really non erm those rules of a
different type and in particular it's
not clear how generalization is affected
by model complexity whether whether the
complexity come in because those nearest
neighbor rule they don't actually have a
notion of complexity and such so that's
kind of the next stage and that's where
we were actually like about like a year
ago like that was very unclear I think
now we understand the connection not
necessarily for theoretical analysis but
we understand how the connection works
so if you look at the classical risk
curve and this is joint work with
Danielle and mine sumak Mandal if you
look at the classical risk or if you see
this you kind of move from underfitting
to underfitting and where does it end
it ends at the point when the training
risk becomes zero but what if you could
continue beyond the zero loss well of
course you cannot what cannot be smaller
than zero it's a square it's some
function which is positive but you can
increase the model complexity even
further and in fact with neural network
that was done routinely and it turns out
that when you are actually increase the
model complexity beyond the
interpolation threshold that follows you
get this double descent and the reason
to call it double descent is because you
have this four
first distance stage the classical
descent and then the risk drops yet
again and this is this more than
interpolating kind of regime you have
the second ascent now every classify
here is or every regret predictor here
is interpolating it has zero loss but as
the complexity of the face increases you
actually have decreasing and potentially
indefinitely decreasing risk by
indefinitely of course it doesn't go to
zero but it has some thoughts to
somebody here in some cases well in
practice it seems to do that there are
some subtleties but it seems to most
cases asymptote and in most cases that
this regime at least in practice is
below that one but we can construct
artificial examples when it goes either
way it's not okay well let me give you
some examples of this just to convince
you that this is a general phenomenon
that goes beyond just a neural net yeah
I think what for boosting we saw this
kind of curve but not I don't think
there was this one yeah so for boosting
we saw that even for neural network even
back like what Brightman was asking
right that's kind of that kind of this
regime it was observed probably 20 Utley
at least more than 20 years ago but
actually we can absorb this double
descent curves for a lot of different
models for fully connected Network
random forests for boosting for you know
like random features of different kinds
for simulated data so it's it seems to
be a very general quite general
phenomenon and I should point out that
other researchers all Serbs or just
recently for neural nets
so okay well but the question is of
course well it's not just to observe
this but the question is what is
actually underlying mechanism why are we
seeing this and let me give you one
example which i think is quite useful at
least for me to illustrate us this is a
very simple model it's just so my data
is one-dimensional just this red stars
and first you build big trees once you
hit zero loss you start averaging the
trees because you cannot build bigger
trees beyond zero it's a little bit
funny but we can discuss this later it
relates to a actually different point
that somehow averaging that's some sort
of small thing but yeah I don't know if
you've seen this method part it's very
similar to that perfect and samples of
random so so let me point out what's
happening here
so suppose so this I think 11 data
points I have 30 rarely features it so
this I just random really features is a
super simple neural network I take
random random features and I just fit
them using linear regressions there is
nothing happening if I take 30 regular
features I get this quite awful jagged
curve when I take 300 it's much nice and
it's smooth and when do I take 3,000
it's essentially the same it's kind of
hard to see the difference so you can
imagine if I take 3 billion that would
look pretty much the same as this one so
you can see our parameterization doesn't
hurt me at all here initially it helps
and then it kind of saturate whatever it
can help it already helped here so
that's the kind of intuition and let me
make this intuition a little bit more
precise with random Fourier features
with alien been proposed in 2007 the
idea if you take random Gaussian weight
and you construct random embedding by
taking in
products or acts you taking a product
with this random Gaussian weight and you
take exponential so it's a little bit
stranger than you were on that but it
makes perfect sense if you want to
approximate the kernel Gaussian kernel
because that's an approximation to
Gaussian kernel and you can grow the
number of random features indefinitely
of course so let's see what's happening
with random Fourier features and the
nice thing here is that we actually know
what this limit is when the number of
features goes to infinity so initially
so this is the number of features times
a thousand so that's like 10,000 20,000
and so on I think this is intimidation a
some things so initially you go through
the few shape curve you get this
interpolation peak and at this point
your loss is zero because the number of
which is actually equals the number what
you need to fit the data exactly and
then you have the second descent stage
and whether the second is edge code it
actually asymptotes to this kernel
machine so you have infinite enrollment
which is equivalent to a kernel machine
and the nice thing is that this kernel
machine is actually the minimum norm
solution for some functional
optimization problem which and I don't
want to discuss now so that means that
why are we getting better results as
we're increasing the number of features
what is happening here is that I am
increasing the number of features the
norm initially increases which is
exactly what you expect here and it hits
a peak at this point but then it starts
to decrease that's the norm of the
solution why does it decrease well very
simple because at the limit the norm of
the solution actually is equal to the
number of the kernel machine and this is
what you can see here and as I have more
and more features I have a bigger space
of solutions which fits zero exactly so
I'm growing the space of possible
functions or possible weights from which
I can choose my minimum norm solution
and when it's large enough it's
basically enough to approximate this
norm accurately so that's why I get this
big improvement initially and then I
kind of saturate because one the
approximation is good
you don't get anything from ecstasy
that's the kind of mechanism underlying
this so more features is better
approximation and well you know the
effect of that saturate now if you look
at that example that I had before you
can actually see that the norm is indeed
decreasing here at 1600 he is 400 and he
like 413 he is 400 it's consistent this
is for real yo and that was for random
in this case because this is fixed first
layer on net so we just solve linear
regression that's the beauty of it there
is a unique solution I just invert the
matrix so the best neural network yeah
so that's what you see right when I tell
you he can have features the norm of my
solution that I get is very close to the
actual kernel machine so I'm
approximating it quite well
there's a large number of features great
of course if I actually just want to do
kernel machine I don't need so many
features I can do it directly but that's
a separate issue okay now if infinite
which optimal well we don't know that we
don't actually have any analysis on all
four kernel machines and maybe some of
the Peterson Alice's can actually that
well so that Peter collaborator did but
maybe can help shed some light on this
but right now we don't have any analysis
of kernel machine for the noisy case for
the noiseless case we can prove it and
basically you can get a bound which is
kind of interesting it's exponential in
the number of data point you can say
okay it kind of limited yes but it's
different from the bound that you get
usually now maybe I'll skip this point
it's not very important now another way
it's also the
another way to you can get so you see
when you minimize norm that essentially
the same as maximizing some notion of
functional smoothness and another way to
do it is to do it by averaging and
that's actually exactly what we do in
those experiments we take this
interpolating trees and we average them
and the average of interpolating trees
is better than any individual tree so
more smoothness always helps so all this
so you can average interpolating
classifiers get a new classifier with
potentially better properties all right
linear regression there is you you can
actually show it in some weak random
feature models and they already have
been some work on that
now how is this sort of would the
philosophy of this I would take this as
a kind of different form of Occam's
razor the classically in machine
learning at least the sort of idea of
Occam's razor was well you're balancing
the loss with some sort of measure of
smoothness yeah that kind of a limit
case of that your thing I'm not going to
worry about the loss at all I am only
going to look at functions which feeds
the date exactly so data is god-given I
am NOT going to mess with it now among
the things which feed the date exactly
I'm going to choose something which is
the smoothest and I have some measure of
mostly this measure of smoothness may be
given by functional norm maybe by some
averaging about some other process
implicitly for like for neural network
with some sort of the caste gradient
descent or some other optimization so
there are all the different ways to
enforce this believe but it's enforced
conditionally on fitting the data
exactly and sort of one remarkable thing
about kernel machine is actually all of
the things coincide with averaging being
an interpretation in terms of the base
and the base and sort of interpretation
in terms of the Gaussian processes all
right so let me summarize the landscape
of generalization so you have kind of
two different regimes at least that's
what we believe now there is as
classical regimes where classical bounds
apply and there is a modern
interpolation regime where you get
something based on this inductive biases
a functional smoothness and now we have
thumb analysis it's still kind of wide
open but we are starting to get some
understanding of that yeah
usually not and if you think about that
random really features kind of example
you can see why you wouldn't expect that
to happen
because well if I have three million
parameters or 3 billion parameters it's
the same thing you're just going to get
the same curve however you can't there
are you can have those so if you just
add noisy features for example you will
see the third phase so it's not
impossible in some models it can appear
but we don't actually see it in any of
the practical at all have you been wise
to any way in the width oh wait
so I am NOT I'm not touching depth at
all here this is explaining the width
the depth I think is a different
mechanism and I'm not going to touch it
today yeah
where there are like connections between
[Music]
so it made so the question is that there
have been recently work showing that
there are kind of when you train this
neural network there are some different
regimes for example the regimes when
they would depth if not the three the
which is not infinite maybe different
like this kernel and I think you mean
like the kernel and adaptive regime for
example right yeah so it may be we don't
really have like a full understanding of
where the slice I believe that whenever
you look at depth you would like I'm
sorry with you would see something like
that it's not dependent doesn't depend
so much on the specific of the
optimization like we see it was fully
connected neural network even with
convolutional you consumers so I I don't
think that of course the exact
configuration of the curve will depend
on various things okay so
now what is all repeating I just need
one to make one more point so
classically we view our fitting is well
when the loss is small right where we're
fit and what do we do when we were if it
will decrease the number of parameters
right by doing some sort of shrinkage
whatever some regularization reducing
the number of parameters some procedure
like that yeah and this is the amazing
thing I think sort of deployed in point
it out either overfitting really is a
band of parameters you can do classical
regularization but you can kind of do
the op you can increase the number of
parameters and move right here and that
has the same effect and that's I think
is something new okay
let me I'll skip this point let me just
okay one one quick point when you look
for this threshold you have to take the
number of clock it's not the number of
data points it's the number of data
points times the number of classes at
least for progression and presumably if
a classification it's not that different
if you have image there that's one
million times a thousand it's 1 billion
parameters you need to fill this exactly
probably none of the current
architectures have 1 billion parameters
you're probably still in the classical
regime it's kind of close to the
threshold but not really on this side if
you train on something like CFR time you
are well here so I think it's important
to keep this in mind that you may be
observing different effects of
regularization and other various you
know tricks that people use depending on
where you are and it may not be
completely obvious where you are in the
plans
it could be less but in our experiments
it seems pretty consistent with what you
would expect so yeah in principle you
can say yeah you can it may be a fewer
than this but I don't think I don't
think it's hundred million like the
biggest models have at least there is it
seems plausible that it specific things
you may see fewer but but you know I
think you're still I don't think you
would expect to fit immunised sorry
image net with something like which has
like hundred million parameters maybe
but it's marginalizes interpolation
threshold is multiplied classes Oh
because you you have to it's basically
not just imagine I have three classes
right then I have made three prediction
that three times as many parameters it's
actually your output is
multi-dimensional you're predicting
three things instead of one if it's just
binary classification you can just view
it as regression so it's one parameter
but if you have to predict like and so
strictly speaking there should be like
number of classes minus one because you
can either okay let me I'm running out
of time let me make a few points about
optimization I don't really have time to
go through it but let me just make some
couple of points here so first what is
optimization on the interpolation if you
look at the classical regime you see
that these things are highly non convex
there are many local minimum minima SGD
actually doesn't converge if you fix the
step size right it just oscillates now
in the modern regimes every local
minimum is global there is a lot of work
on this one I say every of course you
have to put the correct conditions but
informally and what can be shown more
that small batches GT is extremely
efficient and in fact it converges much
faster than
dissent let me just point out how this
works so this is what SGD looks like on
the interpolation so imagine I just have
two data points each data point
corresponds to this constraint and now
what is the cost to gradient descent
stochastic gradient descent should
really be viewed as some sort of partial
cut mark method if you don't know what
it is doesn't matter you do the
following you start here you take a
projection under the it's alternating
projections you take the projection onto
the first constraint you don't complete
it that would be cut marks to complete
this then you take a step over this one
here here and so on and you can see that
if this two lines intersect you actually
have exponential convergence that's
basically what is happening and of
course in practice the things are
nonlinear in there are some you know
many complications but that's kind of
the intuition why is didi so efficient
and in fact converges to zero loss you
can skip this too you can kind of
analyze this in terms of the dependence
of the step size at least for you know
simple convex cases and what you see
actually if there is some sort of
critical size when you increase your
batch size as GD grows up linearly the
efficiency of OCD the step size that you
can take goes up linearly up to this and
then it kind of saturates
so for linear model for convex settings
we can prove this mathematically for
neural networks people have observed
very similar things empirically but
there is a kind of
implication of this which is a following
well let's think about it
what is optimization and modern
diplomatic relation the modern deep
learning you basically over parameterize
that leads to interpolation at least
that's you know maybe one view of
optimization interpolation results in
faster caste gradient descent and then
you use a GPU to basically do that
because sarcastic religious and the some
sort of matrix multiplication is great
on a GPU now let's just think how much
computational again you get well if your
critical step size which I didn't define
but it's kind of the mini batch size for
which you get full convergence rate is
then which happens in practice for some
models I had an example of that then
running SGD on GPU has computational
gain of off n divided by M star when n
as a data science TARDIS ten number and
GPU let's say is hundred times faster
than the CPU so overall for a million
data points you have a factor of
acceleration of ten to the seven hundred
thousand times faster based on us GD and
you're telling a hundred times faster
based on the GPU over CPU so that the
kind of factor that we have and that
that's the difference between a second
and four months that's a kind of
acceleration
GPU is hundred time well maybe it's like
50 times but it's roughly correct it's
okay you know
okay take take it totally like 10 times
faster you have a million times just run
it on GP okay so maybe I just say one
one thing you can learn from deep
learning you character what oh okay
oh wow amazing thank you okay
we can actually learn from deep learning
and in fact we have an implementation of
this as we see you on mama who just
graduated what you can do is that if you
try writing like some standard data set
not very large only on say CPU on lipids
we have you it takes hours for something
like 550 thousand data points if you use
some of this tricks which we basically
learn from deep learning you can reduce
hours to seconds so really those things
are something which we can actually use
and once we understand them we can
exploit even existing method much faster
all right I'm going to sort of two more
slides general summary I would like to
bring up some important points well
first and this is kind of reflecting one
of the point Peter made the new
phenomenon is interpolation it's not of
a parameterization for example classical
methods like Colonel machine so splines
I infinitely over parametrized so there
is not anything new about having a lot
of parameters parameterization enables
interpolation but it's not sufficient as
such because when you regularize you
kind of get rid of it assumption
you empirical laws is a useful
optimization target in these settings it
should not be viewed as a meaningful
statistic for the expected loss it's
just something else optimization is
really quite different under
interpolation and in particular HDD is
overwhelmingly faster than Gd and
finally I would like to make the point
that really understanding linear
regression already gives you a lot of
clues about what to expect not
everything of course can be done using
linear regression but at the very least
as a sanity check I think it's very
important to understand what's true and
what's not true so final slide here is a
kind of summary picture you have the
classical regime where classical bounds
apply there are many local minima there
at least for neural networks and other
kind of non convex problems as JD
converges slowly and you have to
modulate the step size now if you want
to choose the best classical model you
really have to be careful where it is
it's not you have to hit the bottom of
this you more than machine learning
generalization based on functional
smoothness optimization is easy every
local minimum well essentially every
local minimum is global and SGD
converges exponentially and it converges
much faster than gradient descent so
that's kind of the genius of deep
learning in the sense that you know you
can take a very large model and you get
some sort of decent at least
generalization and good optimization and
you get them for free you just throw
more parameters at the problem it's
really quite amazing
here is a collaboration thank you
questions the threshold happens in all
our experiment regression was for the
threshold was actually very close to
where you expect where you expect when
the number of parameters is equal to the
times the number of claw is equal to the
number of data points times the number
of classes it seems to be pretty
reasonable in practice we did not use
like hinge loss so we usually treat
train using l2 loss if you use hinge
loss or you know one some other loss you
would probably see that it's smaller
than that at least on the easy problems
like something like I mean used right
that's easy you can probably get away
with fewer parameters to in many of this
it seems pretty close parameter count
for some cases a different man I don't
think you would because the degrees of
freedom in fulfilling your models will
have this analysis they basically work
the same way I think it really are I
mean it
yeah I don't think I think if you insist
on interpolation and growing the model
and it will be very difficult to remove
the of course if you do some sort of
regularization we kind of went through
that with boosting right - company
number of
well that's the most natural one right
for neural nets that's what the one you
have access to I mean it's like the
bias-variance tradeoff itself right you
would say bias-variance tradeoff have
some measure of complexity right that's
exactly the same right
you don't necessarily you can say well
maybe you should measure it it's some
sort of it's it's what would you expect
it's a guide right this kind of
so you have this picture rotation
if you add regularization you can remove
the peak you wouldn't I mean depending
on the amount of regular well it depends
on the amount of regularization so if
you regular is very lightly you will
just see a much smaller peak or maybe it
will disappear depending on how much
doesn't really affect very much the
limiting case if you regularize heavily
you can remove the peak completely and
it would just look completely you know
what decreasing usually you suffer
though because that large model will not
be as good if you regularly so the
things we can prove for mostly linear
models for which you can actually
analyze this again like other things we
I can tell you about empirical things
empirical observation
finding out is very good yes so you
really when you say interpolation really
what I mean here is that you want to
drive that the model has to be large
enough to drive the l2 arrow to zero you
probably can get something very similar
with just looking at the classification
error but I suspect that it's not so you
can get close to 100% classification
accuracy but I suspect you cannot get
very small out we're over the states I
haven't checked maybe you can and maybe
it is it's difficult right okay so we
will now take lunch break so we will
meet you
[Applause]